let's just let's just capture it and I  see the evaluation bar fully agreeing  with hikaru's assessment of the position  that despite theoretically the two Rooks  and upon being worth more than a queen  it's the activity right and the  difference of activity both this queen  on G1 potentially against the Rooks for  the next few moves is quite considerable  and I think that's why the engine is  preferring the white side  yeah basically okay it's very tempting  not to take at least on A1 yeah that  this Knight comes back yes all the way  to A1 but we have this problem with the  B7 Pawn we have problem with castling  yeah if you could Castle right now I  think he would solve all his problems  but he's one time position